So here's the example number three. Now this is a very informative example. It's going to help you a lot
so as you can see I'm looking at the price section after at 9 15 am right and
I will mark out the low of today and the high of the day and
The midnight open just for you know for my own
Information so the open is one one three three four
So this is the open right you don't have to mark out these
Midnight opens it just tells you from from where you should be you should start looking for the high and the low
you should only start looking for high and low after 12 am okay, and
so as you can see right now we have a
This this liquidity level and then we have the high which is a liquidity level and
if you if you think if you can see these two
Equal relatively equal lows, right? Hi, sorry. These are relatively equal highs
So you can actually drop down to the five minute time frame
Okay, and if it's not clear you can also drop down to the one minute time frame and now you can see that we have a clear
Equal highs zone you can see we have a tap and then we have a tap and we are going down and the time is
919 a.m. Now. This is a clear and I mean clear liquidity zone
Okay, as I have thought above you can see these are clear relative equal lows
Equal highs my bad and they are not the best, but they are okay
so you got to wait for price to sweep that level and
As you can see price swept this level and it also swept the low of the day
So what you should be looking for here is a
Market structure shift, but it doesn't happen now what you can do since the imbalance was so big
You can take your entry from the autoblock level, okay?
There was no marks for the ship and we went straight into the autoblock
So as you can see our daily bias the market structure the oral market structure was bearish
And we are only taking short positions
We would not take long the few the previous example that I showed we should have not taken the long because the market structure was
bearish, but it still works, but I'm saying that if you take
The trades in the overall market direction the wind rate is gonna be higher and I mean much higher
so
The reason why I did not take the entry from this very early gap is because the imbalance is way too big
And if I have my entry around here my stop loss would be very huge, right?
So I would rather miss the trade then take this trade and risk one person with a huge stop loss and a very low reward
level a reward so
You're gonna have taken your entry from this autoblock. Okay, you could have put your stop here
You're gonna have targeted this level you would take some partial tier and then you take your whole trade
You take your all the profits here. So let's see how this plays out. I'm actually not sure how this plays out because I just
Okay, took some partial tier you are break even now and
And boom this hit the take profit level. So what are the key things that we noted?
So if the price
before 915 if you see a liquidity level like this equal highs or a significant high or
You know any type of liquidity guys it doesn't matter and then you see this huge
Displacement after liquidity sweep you take your entry
Yeah, guys it was a very very
Excellent strategy and I use this on daily basis with indices of course
So I hope this you guys like this lecture and I'll see you guys in the next video